ein us forschungsteam hat ein neues
modell der dunkle materie entwickelt und
eine kühne these aufgestellt demnach
könnten die teilchen der dunklen materie
sogar schon vor dem eigentlichen urknall
entstanden sein
roddicks um science-fiction hier gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen der
us-physiker thommy ten kamen von der
john hopkins university ist ebenfalls
wie unzählige andere
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit auf der intensiven suche nach
der dunkle materie doch er ist sich
seiner sache ganz sicher wenn die dunkle
materie ein echtes relikt des urknalls
wäre dann hätten forscher längst ein
direktes signal von ihr in verschiedenen
teilchenphysik experimenten finden
müssen lauten kann ist also der
entstehungszeitpunkt der entscheidende
knackpunkt und zudem auch die erklärung
für alle bisherigen fehlschläge der
physik und tatsächlich steht fest trotz
intensiver suche konnten forschungsteams
weltweit keines der möglichen kandidaten
also der teilchen wie aktionen sims oder
wilms nachweisen keines dieser möglichen
elementarteilchen konnten bisher
dingfest gemacht werden um so die
exotische dunkle materie zu erklären die
gängige lehrmeinung geht davon aus dass
die dunkle materie gemeinsam mit der
materie entstanden ist doch nach der
ansicht des us physiker denken ist das
ein trugschluss
in seiner aktuellen studie stellte ein
modell vor nach dem die teilchen der
dunklen materie schon vor oder während
der kosmischen inflation entstanden sind
eine spannende annahme führt dem
physiker zu diesem ergebnis demnach
beruht die dunkle materie auf einem
scalar feld und seinem sohn zu
vergleichen ist das in gewisser weise
mit dem higgs-boson dessen skala fällt
der materie ihre masse verleiht also
dass hitzfeld so könnte man sich laut n
kann also auch den einfluss des dunklen
scalar feldes auf die dunkle materie
vorstellen diese könnte nämlich anders
als gewöhnliche teilchen schon vor oder
während der inflationsphase entstanden
seien mit der kosmischen inflation wird
in der fachsprache die über licht
schnelle ausdehnung bezeichnet die nicht
nur den kosmos sondern auch die materie
erzeugte manchen definitionen zufolge
läutet die kosmische inflation quasi
auch erst das ende des urknalls ein
hierbei hat sich der durchmesser des
was uns wohl in bruchteilen einer
sekunde 100 mal nacheinander verdoppelt
mit seiner kühnen idee zur entstehung
der dunkle materie ist der us-physiker
übrigens gar nicht allein und erst recht
nicht der erste mit gedanken dieser art
schon andere forschende vor ihm hatten
einst kalla fällt mit person als träger
der dunklen materie angedacht dazu der
physiker wir zeigen erstmals dass ein
skull fällt selbst im einfachsten fall
alle dunkle materie vorbringen kann ohne
dass dies im konflikt mit den daten der
kosmischen hintergrundstrahlung steht
die modelle des forschungsteams legen
nahe dass sich die dunkle materie
tatsächlich vor oder während der
inflation gebildet haben könnte
die berechnungen zeigen dass das dunkle
scalar fällt dabei einen wichtigen
beitrag zur strukturbildung und zur raum
krümmung im frühen kosmos geleistet hat
das entspricht tatsächlich auch den
bisherigen modellen zur dunklen materie
dazu denken
mit dem von uns vorgeschlagenen
szenarium müssen wir zudem keine neuen
formen der wechselwirkung zwischen der
sichtbaren und dunkle materie einführen
schon ab dem jahr 2022 erhofft sich der
forscher weitere indizien und im besten
fall sogar belege für seine neue
hypothese
denn dann startet der esa satellit ins
all das weltraumteleskop ist tatsächlich
spezialisiert darauf die expansion des
kosmos und auch die ursprünge der
materieverteilung ins visier zu nehmen
und die verteilung von galaxien und
anderer materie im kosmos könnte
tatsächlich wichtige indizien bezüglich
der neuen ergebnisse liefern denn das
neue szenario von tankern und seinem
team ist keinesfalls durch experimente
der teilchenphysik zu überprüfen
dazu sind andere astronomische
beobachtungen notwendig denn falls es
die dunkle materie tatsächlich schon vor
der materie als galla feld gegeben haben
sollte hätte sie wohl einfluss auf deren
verteilung genommen dazu denken es wird
sehr spannend sein zu sehen was es über
die dunkle materie enthüllen wird und ob
seine daten uns einen blick in die zeit
vor dem urknall gewähren dunkle materie
die suche nach dem unsichtbaren
anklicken anschauen und raumzeit block
der zukunft abonnieren nur noch ganz
wenige abos bis zu 100.000 raumzeit
block der zukunft ist also kurz vor dem
silbernen play button also hier klicken
und abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran